darauf mit die ihre bis dato mit der
fahrtenbuch aufruf quarks 30 bin ich
wieder heile vom vom züchter und meister
groß wort und habe mich als kind habe
ich mich gefragt ob der richtige für
mich sagt maxi mensch tier punkt und
darum glaube ich also weil es jetzt
menschlich alle teams info habe mir da
schon immer gemacht und haben es nicht
macht ja schon immer gemacht da ist
quasi clooneys recht also stücke gewisse
moralische vorstellungen dürfen
aber ganz andere frage ist gibt es dann
vielleicht nur es moralisch höchst
seriös oder also
gehörig gerechtigkeit wo immer menschen
auf die gleiche stufe wie sie gemacht
und mit dir und
ja und jetzt ganz anders oder also ich
würde mich das nicht aber ich sitze da
das fleisch essen und musik
ja ich muss mit dem widerspruch leben
eigentlich ist es
aber ich mache es trotzdem
[Musik]